-Our next guest is a very
talented actor and writer
who received four
Emmy nominations this year
for his work on the hit series
"Ted Lasso,"
including Best Supporting Actor
in a Comedy Series.
New episodes of "Ted Lasso"
are released Fridays
on Apple TV+.
Let's take a look.
-Well, that was interesting.
-Oh, thank you, Doc. Yeah.
A little something we came up
with back in Kansas.
See, what we're doing is --
-You pretend
to be an ass [bleep]
so the team make you their
common enemy and not Jamie.
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah.
-Spot on.
-Got it right away.
-Mm-hmm.
-Has it ever worked?
-Uh...
-Tryin 'to remember.
-Uhh, chuck E. Cheese.
-Chuck E. Cheese.
That's right. Yeah.
We were at an arcade/pizza joint
in Lincoln, Nebraska
and one of our offensive linemen
got his head stuck
in a VR machine.
Ended up getting the entire meal
and all our beverages comped
for free, so...
-Maybe they don't have
chuck E. Cheese here.
-Oh, yeah. You all might call it
something different here like
Charles Edgar Cheeserton III
or something, right?
-Please welcome back
to the show
our very good friend
Brendan Hunt.
How are you, Brendo?
-I'm good.
How are you?
-I'm wonderful.
-I'm actually a little annoyed,
Seth, because I was --
I was willing to fly
to New York.
I would have jumped
right on a plane.
I was told you weren't
having people in the studio!
-Yeah.
-And then old yellow dress
comes out,
and I'm an ass [bleep]
here in my house.
-Yeah, and it gets worse
because our next guest
is also in studio.
-[ Screams ]
[ Laughter ]
-Now, to be fair,
I took it upon myself
to not ask that of you
because you are a new dad.
Congratulations, Brendan.
There's your little guy.
Right away, you're force-feeding
Arsenal into his blood stream.
How is he -- How is he taking
to watching football matches
with you?
-Oddly enough,
he really seems to like it.
I guess because it's just
a giant sea of green
and, you know,
the only thing that Daddy
actually cares about,
so maybe that draws him in
a little bit.
But he has now watched
more soccer games
at the age of almost 7 months
than I had by the time
I was 26 years old.
-Yes. You came to it --
You came to it very late.
I watched a game
with my 5- and 3-year-old,
and I thought they would
be excited for it.
And the only thing they liked
was when a player got hurt,
and the doctors ran out
and sprayed their ankles.
They thought it was amazing
that there were just, like,
doctors on the scene.
-"They're cleaning him, Daddy."
-"They're cleaning him up."
So, 20 nominations
for "Ted Lasso."
This is a show you both star in,
write on, created.
And morning of, I mean,
you guys I think probably
had some hope that there
would be some nominations.
You couldn't have imagined
it would be 20.
How did you find out the news?
-Well, yeah.
I mean, we had done all right
in the previous ones,
you know, this season,
so like, "Yeah, we'll
probably get one or two."
But I was hoping
to sleep through it
because then I don't
have to worry about nothin'.
And, again, I have...
at that time.
So he had other plans.
So at that point I'm having my
Cheerios and keeping him alive.
It was just like,
"All right. I'll turn it on."
And...yeah.
Then, you know, we got nominated
and Jason gets nominated,
and then, like,
the show's over.
Like, "Oh. Okay.
I thought there were usually
more categories, but all right."
And I didn't know that they were
only showing part of them.
So then my manager is calling me
with like, you know --
as if he was on, like, a rocket
skateboard of some kind.
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Shouting gibberish ]
And all these things.
So...yeah.
It was an all right
little morning.
I'm just so happy so many people
from the show
got nominated, though,
like, you know, down into
the "creative art" categories
and everything.
That was cool.
-It was great.
You know, we talked to your
co-star, Hannah, this week.
I should say last week.
And she was saying that you
guys are as close as it seems,
and one of the really cool
things in a category
with eight nominees
that you're in,
three of the other seven
are your co-stars.
It just must be
such a cool feeling.
-Yeah.
I mean, it's -- it's --
But it's already ruined our
relationships with each other.
-Sure.
Well, I was gonna say.
I mean, I know
from our friendship,
I know you to be
a really petty person.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
I mean, as soon as you started
getting nominated for Emmys,
even though I wasn't on
any TV shows,
I was just like, "What, him?!"
-Yeah.
And I carry that with me
to this day.
It's gotten me so far.
-You would text and say,
"I thought this was my year."
And I'd say, "Brendan, you're
not on a television show."
-Ugh. You and your dumb reality.
Dump on my dreams.
-Hey, this --
So, again, you know,
I was sort of present
at creation,
not of "Ted Lasso" but of
when you became a soccer fan.
Because I was just like you.
And it wasn't until we lived
together in Amsterdam
that I think we realized
what a beautiful game it was.
But this really is special.
You got to be
one of the falconers
for a game in L.A.
Tell me about what the role
of the falconer is at this game
and why this team has falcons.
-I wish I could tell you why.
-Sure.
-That part, really,
I guess because --
Oh, I just figured it out.
Because if you mix up
the letters of LAFC,
you have two-thirds of "falcon."
-[ Fingers snap ]
-Boom. Great.
So now we know that one.
But, yeah.
It's like the ceremonial
pregame first pitch, basically.
It's, like --
They have this falcon.
And someone releases it,
and it flies around,
and it catches a little chip
that has the logo
of the opposing team,
and the falcon tears that
to bits.
What you don't know
until you do it --
And, you know, great honor.
I was so happy to do it.
I had seen it happen many times.
You have there in your hand
a picture of me being pooped on.
That is the exact moment...
-Really?
-...the falcon is poop--
You can't see it
because of the J.J. Abrams flair
coming out
of the falcon's butthole.
-Right. That's why
they put that light there.
-Probably. Probably.
They know what's up.
Yeah, and I, like,
wiped it on my back,
and I didn't know
that it was on my back,
and so I had falcon poop
for the entirety of that game,
which was also
a humbling 4-1 home loss.
-Oh, man.
-So I'm a good-luck charm
for LAFC, and I'm very proud.
-It is -- It's kind of nicer
than a first pitch, though,
because a first pitch
you can really reveal
that maybe you're bad
at a sport.
But nobody is gonna say like,
"Oh, that's his first falcon."
[ Laughter ]
You -- This is --
We were talking
about this recently
because Amber Ruffin,
who also worked with us
at Boom Chicago,
was wearing a blond wig recently
and speaking in sort of a --
a broken European accent.
And I was like, "Oh, you're
doing Uda from Boom Chicago.
This was a sketch
that you used to do
with Oscar winner
Jordan Peele at Boom Chicago.
There you are.
You're playing Bono.
And there is our friend
Jordan Peele.
Is it weird now to look back at
your time living in Amsterdam?
Or do you just have
fond memories?
-Oh, gosh. Only fond memories.
You know?
I mean, but it's fun.
Like, we had, you know,
crazy partying times there
on top of getting our chops up
doing constant performing
for drunk people.
-Talking -- Speaking of,
you talk about crazy times,
and I want to make sure
we get to this.
Talk about the Gonzo parties
you used to do
and the role you played in them
and how much worse it would have
been if cellphones were around.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, yeah.
There were these parties that
were hosted by Australian Dave,
and they were full-on
just "wear whatever the hell
you want" costume parties.
Like, not themed.
Just go for it.
And so I would literally just
dig through a pile of clothes
and put on crazy stuff and --
Yeah, I often think about, like,
the fun that kids have today
has just got to be ruined
and curtailed by the notion
that you're gonna be online
at any moment.
We did not have that.
I feel like maybe we were
the last chunk of people
having ridiculous behavior
out in public
that we'll never have
that chance again
without fear of repercussion.
And we've lost
something there, Seth.
"Back in my day, we would
have to walk to school. Ooh."
-I like that if you went --
If you said, "My friend Dave's
hosting a party,"
you'd say, "Oh, that's
probably a normal party."
But if you said, "Australian
Dave is hosting a party,"
it'd be like, "Oh [bleep].
I hope there aren't cameras!"
Hey, buddy, congratulations
on all your nominations.
You're nominated a couple times
for writing, as well,
which are also so well-deserved.
And thank you.
It's always great
to see your face.
-Great to see you.
Thanks for having me.
-"Ted Lasso"
is streaming on Apple TV+
with new episodes released
every Friday.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."